hey what's up guys welcome back to the
samuel and amanda show i'm samuel and
i'm amanda
and on this podcast or youtube video
depending on how you watch or listen
we discuss money marriage and
life so we're gonna take questions from
last week's episode
a lot of questions last week were about
more about marriage i think
okay yeah um marriage relationships not
so much money
we've got a lot of money questions
recently like last week but um
drop a comment below if you're watching
on youtube that would be fantastic
and while you're doing that amanda how
has your week been
the week has been amazing it's been so
sunny literally we've lived outside
we've got some bi-fold doors in the
playroom and
i've just had them open all week for the
kids and they've just been going in and
out of the house
playing with mud making mud coffees
ruby has and um having barbecues and
just living up in the hot tubs that it's
been
it's felt like a holiday i think yeah
the weather's been really good um in
fact you know what that hot the hot tub
was
the best when we bought it we said this
is either gonna be the best investment
or the worst investment we ever got and
i think it's slowly becoming the best
yeah yeah so although you make the week
sound like it's just literally been
paradise and bliss
it hasn't this week has been a tough
challenging week
at least for me for you yeah um oh man
i've just been
i've had so many things go wrong this
week
on the property side of the business we
had some deals fall through
we had some builders walk off site
because that i think they were trying to
fleece me do you think they were trying
to fleece me
i think so honestly and and well what
are you trying to
tell what happened a little bit well the
builders are basically just like they
were
trying to try to get more money and then
i was like no that's not what's in the
contract
and i think there's a lot of builders
man they just tend to be so so
i wasn't having it at all was i no you
weren't and
and then they just basically were like
well we need more money others we can't
continue
and like if it's a case of if they're
like knocking something back it's oh we
found something that we didn't expect
yeah i think that's fine
but then we just sort of you know i hate
it when we use corona virus
for everything i know it's such an
excuse oh it's because of corona things
have gone up now i'm like well
i'm sorry you quoted a few months ago
you've just started you can't just
suddenly go actually things have gone up
it's been a really annoying week so they
just walked off site
and i've had to replace them which i'm
kind of in the middle of doing right now
we've got about four different projects
going on all at once
and it's been a little bit tough but
i've been doing that while amanda's been
in the hot tub with the kids
having barbecues um which which has been
fun
but um cool so anything else you've been
up to
um i can't really think of anything else
it's so funny because i look at amanda's
diary
and it just says things like that going
to the play train yeah okay we've had a
picnic in the park
in the sunshine you know it's also
really funny
amanda has just got
today or yesterday a dream
oh my goodness guys my car that i
ordered my
new electric car which you're gonna find
out what car it is yeah you'll find out
soon
it's annoying because there's a delay
it's my land rover discovery the sport
discovery sport
and was taken away today and it got
delivered
it's like a proper moment we should
definitely
usually do a vlog on your channel about
that car
it's a big gray mom car
and it is cool and i've just got it for
the foreseeable future because
we don't know when my new car's going
when we have guests now i'll make amanda
just park
you know a little bit away so people
don't come and see the car should be
fair what what car is it's a bmw
yeah it's a bmw series but it's um
it's called a grand i think grand tourer
or something like that i've never even
actually seen it on the road before
but now funnily since i've had it i keep
seeing
that's how it works it's the law of
attraction yeah yeah all right lawrence
carlos says
you two look a very lovely couple amanda
has a permanent
pleasant smile there is a woman a wife a
mother in her
i like the way she carries herself
beautiful on the face and also in the
brain
wait that's that's my that's my woman
yeah that's my mom
it's very true you know what i'll tell
you something funny about last week last
week the
episode that we did was about how some
of the nasty things people have said
about mandy having miscarriages and
horrible stuff
so for the thumbnail that's like the
picture that we use for the for the
cover of the
youtube video i thought well let me just
skip through the video and i'll pause it
on a point where our faces are quite
serious or sad
and then i'll screenshot it and then
i'll put some text over it and i'll use
that as the cover photo of the youtube
video
so i'm going through and regularly my
face looks angry or
sad or still or serious going through
the i'm going through the video
amanda just had a permanent all over the
video
i'm like how are you just smiling like
throughout the entire 20 minute video
and then and then for a split second
that's when i got the shot that's when i
got the shot so you're right
you're right all right thank you very
much thanks laurence andrew harbour i
love andrea hey andrea
andrea hey andrea andreas andrew says
hey youtube
loving your new show question for samuel
what is your cooking skills like and
have you ever cooked a special meal for
amanda
good question andrea
go on you answer it's a question for you
and then i'll add to what you say
well i think it's better for you to
answer that question because it's
impossible for me to say how good my own
cooking is
oh okay okay well first of all samuel
doesn't cook
but you have actually made me once
egg on toast samuels just made me
breakfast i think this is the first time
you've ever cooked for me isn't it
yeah ever um
i was just teasing him well i thought
that you wouldn't be able to make it
and and this is one time i thought there
was some time i got
he's never i was like did i did i cut
once for you
but the one time he did cook for me yeah
um it was when i was still working and
he said babe
i've got you a nice dinner when you get
home i'm gonna have it plated for you
it's gonna be
you're gonna love it when you get home i
was like oh samuel's prepared something
awesome
right i get her it was a lovely meal
however it was a it was a roast dinner
from toby carvery that he'd got
went and picked it all and then he just
plated it up when i got home
so that's about you know listen i
did food and nutrition at school i'll
have you know i got a d
infinity that's not too good i've got a
d in food and nutrition so do i know how
to cook
um not really no i wonder what would you
actually eat
if well before we got married i had
someone just cut my meals yeah i know
someone was just i had someone wrong but
if you have to do it yourself i don't
think
it's probably a safe bet that you can do
i had a cleaner i had a cook
before we got married yeah you know i
would never did that kind of stuff just
because i'm not very good at it
and i'd rather spend my time on the
business
but i'm kind of dependent on amanda for
food yeah
but yeah so i'm happy to provide good
food as well so
man is a great job we're a good team
okay um
says it'll be lovely to hear about your
two weddings
sometime being a ghanaian
and british who married in america
american
it was great to have the two different
ceremonies we had three days of
celebrations
so we did have two weddings
we had the english wedding which was
kind of like the proper
that was like that was when yeah we were
saying
we like officially so in our mind that
was when we got married and that was
july 2015
and then we also had the lobola the
money marriage the african ceremony
and that was in january 2015. as far as
your family was concerned
we were like married there yeah so they
just saw me as
their their son at that point and
the difference is in them well why don't
you why don't you talk about what the
what happens at like a libola so a
liberal
is a ceremony that you have and it's
when
the guy who's going to marry the girl
comes to the family's house and before
he comes he's given a list
um and lots of different things and they
basically
add up to an amount so it used to be a
bride
a bride price paid in cows but nowadays
it's paid like
you know in money so um you
you came to the house and then you're
given this list and then you know how
much you're supposed to give and you
basically
pay this money over to the family and
it's basically like a thank you
um for looking after my wife to be the
woman that she is today
and it's like it's like a small amount
like maybe like
or 1500 least that's what she told me
when we started
dating when we started dating samuel was
i said oh there's this thing that we do
but i mean it's kind of traditional but
you know i don't really think my parents
will be it's not that deep to them
before we just tell you to give
a token amount but you know i think
they'll just do it because it
wasn't a token amount it it bled me dry
yeah so yeah i i just thought my parents
would just do it it's like oh this is
what we used to do but it's not going to
be but yeah
they like made him go all out and i mean
thankfully samuel just came in and
embraced it and
just like did it and honored that and my
parents loved that and i loved it too so
yeah yeah so that was good so we we
honored that so it was
interesting wasn't it at the beginning
because i'm zimbabwean
i was born in zimbabwe moved here so i'm
kind of like a bit of birth but
mostly zimbabwean so culturally there
was
i think when when we met it was like oh
what what's it going to be like
well the thing is some of my family
thought that her family would take in
the mickey
like what the heck you have to pay money
to get
like this sounds like a scam what the
heck are you talking like
thousands and thousands of pounds like
what so
you know some of my family thought that
so there's a little bit of
i wouldn't say conflict but it was hot
it was
not even hard for me because i'm not
really that bothered but for me to be
like oh yeah by the way i have to
you know play in english culture it
sounds really weird
it sounds like what however in
zimbabwean culture
it's completely absolutely normal yeah
luckily i spent time in different parts
of africa
in zambia it's very similar i've spent a
month in zambia
and i've been there like ten times not
ten times maybe six times
prior to getting married so i kind of
not only understand the culture but i
also
would like to consider myself quite
open-minded and generally quite
open to embrace different cultures and
stuff so for me it wasn't like a massive
deal and i kind of understood it i spoke
to your brother about it yeah and it
kind of it kind of made sense actually
and i thought
you know what if you if if if you've
raised
like the english people now are just
going to be freaking out but
if you've raised your daughter
and they are an asset in your household
and you've spent money on their
education and you spent all this time
and energy and
and they're a great asset and then
someone comes along
obviously it's you know totally normally
natural but then says right i want to
take her and start a family you're kind
of almost losing not losing the door but
you're just
you know it's it's really also a
gratitude thing it's just a way of
saying
you know what thank you for raising
this person beautifully thank you for
keeping them safe and protected and
thank you for providing them a great
education and
because you know so for me i was so
happy to be able to marry amanda i was
just like well i'm so grateful
i'm happy to to pay this this
labolo amount and also it's like it's
kind of like you're never allowed to
say the amount are you it's no it's kind
of we're very i'm very transparent i
wouldn't care but it's very
frowned upon in the culture because it's
it's also different girls
or women depending on how well educated
you've been and and everything depends
on the
so if you are very working class and
you've not really had a great education
it would be a lesser amount wouldn't it
yeah but if you're
more a more affluent kind of area and
well educated which you have
it's a higher amount but for me
i didn't mind that but then your family
had their own issues
with me yeah my dad was like
what bro what are you talking about man
when he heard it i was going out with a
white guy english he was just like
and i think he just pictured something
just totally different
but just just for just for like so you
understand
he didn't know me he never met me amanda
i don't know if amanda told him but he
found out that amanda was dating and was
seeing somebody and by the way again
like when we started dating and stuff
it was a long-distance relationship yeah
very serious
um started to get to almost as not
friends but
you know we we weren't messing around
catching and getting married we weren't
messing around
yeah yeah we weren't um like you know we
met
some club and was sleeping together and
you know we were talking about marriage
and creating a future together
very serious and when your dad
found out he was living in zimbabwe yeah
because your family moved across but
your dad hadn't
um you know he wasn't in the country he
was working in zimbabwe
and he wasn't having it yeah he was just
like uh
uh and i think for him it was just he
was probably just thinking like the
cultural differences like oh my goodness
like
we have to do this we have to do this
like this this person will
you know might not go by what the
culture
you know you know the different
traditions and things that we have
so i think it was just like as well it
might be slightly stereotypical but i
think from
your dad's perspective he might have
been thinking like
because you're from quite a strict
christian
background as it happens i'm as well you
know
my mom um you know as a committed
christian i am as well
and i think that your dad was kind of
thinking awesome
english white person they're probably
just going to be wanting to sleep with
you
part of it might be you were the first
daughter i don't even know if it was
like a race thing or even a cultural
thing i think part of it might have been
your dad you've been like oh la la la la
you're even in a relationship at all
yeah
i'm just using the white card as a bit
of a
reason for you to just you know i don't
know what exactly it was
um and also in in the culture of
zimbabwe when you want to marry
someone um it's so we could spend so
long
i know it's so like there's so many
different things like
you can't you can't go to the dad direct
because that's kind of like whoa
so as a man you have to go to the dad's
sisters or the dad's closest women to
him yeah
but your dad's got sisters you've got
aunties so i would go to amanda's
aunties and
express my interest and then the aunties
would go to the dad and and then
blah blah blah yeah because it's the
present but because her dad was so anti
it was like no
i thought her aunties aren't gonna sell
me properly
they're gonna be like some guy she's
like a nice guy
he's white he's from england and her
dad's come back
nope that's what's gonna happen so i
thought
you know so we we spoke about it and
amanda was like
really you're upset yeah i was i was
just like oh my god because he was kind
of like saying look
you realize how amazing samuel was
because at the time he hadn't met him
he didn't know me at all yeah did not
follow me on social media
didn't know anything i don't even think
he knew my name he just knew
amanda was dating somebody he was a
white english man
and he was not having it right so i
thought i'm not
i don't want to i don't want i i want to
play my cards right right now
i want to meet him you know and
i wrote a letter didn't i yeah to your
dad
addressed it dear mr machekin younger
and just and wrote a
really concise articulate letter
about my intentions and i didn't say
um you know oh i want to marry her or i
want to get together
you know but i just i respectfully asked
that he would
give me an opportunity to meet with him
i said i know you're coming to england
i wrote a big long letter and i said i
know you're going to be in england
at christmas and i would be very
honoured and humbled if i could have the
opportunity to meet with you
um over the over the christmas period
just for just for one
you know one afternoon and and then you
can hear me out
and meet me in person because i thought
if he if he meets me in person
it will change the game um but
fortunately the letter was enough
yeah and as soon as he got the letter he
rang me up
and and and was his heart completely
changed and
he very quickly gave me his blessing to
marry amanda
and the rest is history i struck while
the iron was hot
he got married like a few months well we
got married
when i met your dad within a month we'd
had the african-american
yeah bang that's why i didn't mind about
the ebola he's an action ticker he is
yeah i was just like i'm good i'm good
all right
cool let's see what else we've got what
other questions we got
okay so emmanuel says
what is the best gift you've received
from each other for your birthdays or
wedding anniversaries
oh okay i would say
and i'm such a cry i get so emotional
but one of the best gifts that you gave
me
she's coughing choking up just thinking
about it she's done it
was that um it was a little gift box and
it was when for every day of the year
you'd
written something uh something that you
admired about me or something you know
like a nice thing about me that you
loved about me
and it was just so sweet it like oh
it was just like literally so like i
have it and have it out and then i could
just pick out a card
and then just read and it will just like
remind me of
a reason why samuel loves me so it's
really really sweet yeah it was just
when we got married every day i secretly
wrote something down
that i loved about amanda or just
something sweet that she'd done that day
or whatever
i did that for a year and then i put i
put them all together and i
made this little jewelry box and put
them in
little homemade drawers and uh it's
interesting because that was the best
gift that i gave you but that was
actually
a gift for me you know just doing it so
okay um patricia quilty what's happening
you amazing
she says how did samuel propose to you
amanda
oh okay so following on from the story
about my dad
he actually proposed to me that so when
he met my dad it was christmas it was
christmas
and on christmas eve i just thought
samuel and my dad
are getting to know each other they've
just met for the first time so there's
no way like you know there's going to be
any talks of married straight away
they're just going to get to know each
other
little did i know samuel and my dad had
been speaking
and they'd samuel had asked for my dad's
blessing to you know
um propose to me so on christmas eve
that night
he put on the tv he's like oh i've got
you know a little video that i want to
show so it was my family and samuel
and he played this video and it was just
like a little montage of
you know memories that we've made since
we've been together and i was kind of
thinking like oh that's so sweet but i
was thinking like oh i wonder what my
dad's thinking because you know he's
just like kind of getting to know samuel
so i was a little bit like oh on edge
and i was thinking where is this going
and then he was like oh you know i know
it's christmas tomorrow but i've got a
gift that i want to give you today can
you open it and i was just like okay and
it's a big box
i opened the box and inside the box was
another box and the other box another
box up and it was getting smaller and
smaller and smaller
until it got to like a little box and
even then i was still kind of thinking
like hmm
and then he took the little box off me
got down on one knee and then all my
family had their phones out like oh my
goodness
like cheering him on i'm there bawling
my eyes out because i'm just
like so emotional but over the moon as
well and he proposed then christmas eve
2015
2014 and no 2014 2014
2014 and oh my goodness it was just like
the sweetest and it was so unexpected as
well
and yeah i was just so glad because
obviously you've been speaking to dad
so oh it was just like amazing it was
the best night ever so that's how he
proposed it was just like the sweetest
thing
ever and by that point me and dad were
best buddies yeah they were ready and to
be honest ever since
me and your dad have been really close
oh yeah so you know now
he's got to know you and like he's loved
you
and now you know i consider myself fully
zimbabwean and you know
we yeah i mean your family your mom's
around at the moment
um you know your mom and dad are amazing
and they're they're really happy
together as well and they love the
grandkids and
it's really beautiful and i'm just
really glad
how it panned out it was a that wasn't
answered a prayer yeah
that was an answer to prayer okay cool
uh next
lennon do you frequently argue
and was there a point in the
relationship where you nearly split up
how do you overcome things like this
no we don't we don't frequently argue
and we've never we've never really
argued or even got to the point where we
want to split like we've never
never been down that road thankfully
thank god no we've never we never have
i mean we don't really argue at all do
we no
we we just we just kind of live in
harmony
yeah we have sometimes have a discussion
or like disagreement we don't agree on
for example
i'll be careful go on that could be like
something that we could argue about is
vaccines
i knew you were gonna say oh the reason
i said be careful is because it's a very
controversial oh i'm sorry
i didn't realize and you told me that's
the only thing that keeps things not
political
and uh that's the only thing that i
would say that we
don't 100 agree on but even then we
don't argue about
it it's just you know no because if
you're on the same team as someone
it's like me and my brother my business
partner russell
we we sometimes debate things but it's
like what's going to be the best
yeah for the company if we're having a
debate it's like
if we're debating something it's right
what's going to be best for
for for our family it's not what's going
to be best for me what's going on for
you what do
i want yeah what do you want it's what's
going to be best
you know so if we're talking about you
know vaccines it's what's going to be
what's going to be best
you know and i might say um you know i
mean amanda's
very anti-vaccines i personally think
that
um i said amanda's very anti-vaccine oh
no i'm not antsy no no no she was just
very nodding
i was like and then i usually win an
argument in it
no no i'm not anti i'm i'm pro vaccines
but i think that there's a time and a
place
so yeah i mean we probably shouldn't
even get into it because that's another
conversation in itself moving
on all right cool uh joe williams
hi samuel i've always wanted to date
african women but i've never had the
opportunity to encourage
what's been your experience so far and
if you were to god forbid separate would
you ever be able to date for example an
english woman since you were used to
different culture
this is a random question you're a great
couple amanda looks beautiful amazing
listen thank you i i
just love amanda for amanda
you know so
like it's i don't see amanda as an
african woman i see amanda as amanda
so it's kind of it's kind of a hard
question really to answer
so i don't really know what to say apart
from that i don't know what you have to
say
yeah i don't know like say it say if we
broke up god forbid
i wouldn't think oh i'm kind of off
white men because of that
yeah again it's just put her off for
life yeah no i don't think so i don't
think so
yeah i i i can't i can't imagine myself
with anybody else anyway so it's a hard
question to answer but i guess before i
was with amanda
i guess that's that's easy to talk about
um
i've dated i was in a relationship with
an indian lady
we dated for i don't know how long
exactly i think maybe six to twelve
months
wonderful beautiful lady only good
things to say about her
i have dated a white english lady as
well
that was a little bit of a nightmare but
that's another story
um and that's it really i think i've
only really had like
maybe two or three relationships ever
and one of them was when i was very
young i was like 12
when i was at school so three in total
including when i was a kid
so um i'd be prior to being amanda i
didn't mind and then i met amanda i just
thought amanda
was amazing so i don't think race comes
into it too much and in terms of culture
i love i love zimbabwe and culture i
think zimbabwean culture is awesome
but i didn't like meet amanda or want to
get with amanda because i love
zimbabwean culture
you know so yeah i think that's about it
what do you think
i don't really have anything else to
wear anyway i appreciate your question
um tom says how do you combine business
and romance interesting question because
when i was leaving my corporate job and
i said i'm leaving because i'm gonna
do my own thing and work with my husband
lots of people were like oh my goodness
i could never work with my partner
how can you do that give it some time oh
goodness
like things like that but stupid man and
what did you say i look stupid i know
it's so silly like
how do you how do you how did what did
it say how do you how do you combine
my romance i don't know i mean i think
if you get on
just generally then i don't really see
it being an issue
like you're a team in your marriage or
in your relationship
and you're a team in business as well
like you want the same thing you've got
the same goals so yeah and in terms of
like romance
i mean if we're out doing viewings or
whatever
we're working but then you might it
might just be a look
or maybe in between you'll just go out
for a coffee and have a little
life is just i think i don't really see
it as super separate i won't be like
now i'm in work mode so don't flirt with
me or don't
yeah you know it's just um i don't
really think about it too much but
i definitely think we probably do
combine romance and pictures yeah yeah
we do
so um there was a lot about marriage
some of you guys now thrown up at home
some of you guys like what
what but hey we did say samuel amanda
show
money marriage and life and today was
definitely about a lot about marriage
about cultural differences being an
interracial couple
um what should we talk about something
like
how um we are
an interracial couple that kind of sucks
you can come up with yeah you can come
up with
that but yeah yeah i mean as i say man
any questions you got it's all good
drop it in the comments um so amanda
follow words of wisdom my final words of
wisdom for this week
is don't let your happiness be
controlled by
things that you can't control so if you
can't control it then
don't don't let it affect you because
there's no point stressing about it
because
you're just going to stress yourself out
yeah over nothing
so only focus on things that you can
control if you can't control it then you
know
i agree with that but i also think you
control a lot more than you think
like for example i could have just gone
oh my dad doesn't want us to be together
in a manner
oh i can't control that all right bye
and that no no no
i control i took control of the
situation
life is ninety percent what you make it
yeah
how you control it and it's just ten
percent how you take it yeah i think
what amanda's saying is
don't get stressed out about that ten
percent i know you're just gonna go i
can't accept this
you know maybe if you um i don't know if
if someone that you love is is not well
or whatever
look i'm gonna stand by them and support
like i can't do anything about it so i'm
not gonna
i'm not gonna get all hoped up or if
something happens if you lose some money
or
have a car accident or end up having you
know a real
ugly big mom's car as your as your
courtesy car
you know you can't get stressed out
about it
you just have to be happy in the
situation
so love it amanda thanks enjoy your wine
cheers drop your comments and questions
below we'll answer next week
and we'll see you real soon thanks for
watching guys bye